vsauce kevin here with a video giveaway
idea for youtube's most prolific
philanthropist
mr beast it gives everyone who watches
it
including you a chance to win 1
million dollars here are the rules of my
hypothetical contest mr beast makes a
video and if that video gets
one single like only one thumbs up in
the first
24 hours the person who liked the video
wins
a million bucks however if more than one
person
smashes that like button or nobody
clicks it at all
then no one wins anything
oh and another thing only mr beast can
see whether
anyone has liked the video everyone is
playing the game
blind to the results you'll have no way
of knowing whether you're the first
and only person to like the video or
the 10 millionth so
what do you do do you click like and
magically hope you're the only person
who did do you
like the video just to troll the contest
hoping it'll ruin
someone else's chances do you do nothing
and forego the chance of winning feeling
safe in the knowledge that you didn't
ruin it for
anyone else here's the biggest question
is it even possible to win this game
welcome to the platonia dilemma
a mathematical game devised by cognitive
scientist
douglas hofstadter his version went like
this 20 people were sent
telegrams by fictitious oil baron sn
platonia if only one person replied to
the telegram
that person would win one billion
dollars
if nobody or more than one person
replied
no one wins anything collusion or
secretly working together was strictly
forbidden
and participants didn't even know who
the other 19 potential respondents were
anyway so like
they couldn't all get together and agree
that only
number 15 would reply and the rest of
them would
split the uh billion dollars you know
20 different ways
in an attempt to rationally solve this
dilemma in your favor
you face four important questions what
should i do
what will other people do what should i
do after knowing what other people will
do
what will other people do after knowing
that i know what they
do and the answers to these questions
are i don't know not sure no idea
and who knows because the thing is
the more rational we all are the more
the right
answer keeps changing
cheating the game is a good example of
this and we'll get to that in a bit but
to make the best of the platonia dilemma
your rationality alone isn't
enough no no we need
super rationality hofstetter describes
super rationality as a state of knowing
the perfectly rational thing to do
but also knowing that everyone else
knows and will behave
the exact same way so you know
they know you know they know and you
know
they know you know that process goes on
forever and
everyone arrives at the same
exact conclusion it's like a rational
singularity hofstadter decided the best
way forward the
super rational thing to do was to roll
a 20-sided or icosahedral die and commit
to only replying to the telegram if his
pre-chosen number came up like the
number one
here's why the best odds for someone to
win this game
occur when you transcend the rationality
hyperloop you have to move beyond simply
trying to figure out
what should i do what will other people
do etc
and create an artificial probability
mechanism if all 20 people in the game
act
super rationally they'll each roll a
20-sided die
once and commit to replying to the
telegram
only if they roll a one
that leaves about a 37 percent chance of
somebody winning it is possible for
no one to roll a one and it's also
possible for
more than one person to roll a one so
that means that
your personal odds of winning are
not one out of twenty which would be
five percent
no your odds of winning personally are
about
two percent but at least this super
rational system leaves the game up to
math
instead of everyone just guessing
why not cheat though
seriously uh why don't you just lie and
reply
anyway if there's only a 37 chance
that somebody won that way you would be
the winner if
none of the other 19 players rolled
a one genius
but if you know that then that means
other people know that and they'd cheat
too which would
instantly wipe out the boosted odds of
winning by
lying the rational thing for
you to do is cheat but if
everyone thinks that they'll also cheat
and
then everyone loses that's why the
super rational thing to do is
not cheap hofstetter even suggested
removing the cheap temptation entirely
by using a die rolling machine that
instantly replied to platonia
if and only if he rolled a one
but this is all just theoretical right
it's really hard to do that with these
sticky things
we don't actually know how people would
behave in a platonia-like situation
right wrong it actually happened
hofstadter convinced scientific american
to run what he called a luring lottery
in a 1983 meta magical themis column
the basic rules were a little different
but the essence was the same
the prize for one lucky lottery winner
was 1 million bucks
which would be divided by n where n
equals the number of
entries mailed in there was however a
crucial twist
instead of each reply counting as one
entry you could write any number on the
postcard and it would count for that
many
entries so a postcard with a one on it
counts as
one entry a postcard with one million on
it counts as
a million entries a higher number of
entries gave the player a better chance
of winning but it also reduced
the potential prize money some people
submitted googleplex entries which is
10 raised to a google others wrote
mathematical expressions that filled the
postcard resulting in incalculably high
numbers which meant the total entries
hit such an
unfathomable number that scientific
american was
unable to choose a winner it became
impossible and even if they could have
the winner would have received 1 million
dollars
divided by such a high end that the
prize would have worked out to an
infinitesimal fraction
of one cent the takeaway here is that
coupling
unlimited entries with people pursuing
their own
self-interest while recognizing that
everyone
else would do that too quickly bulldozed
that
one million dollar prize into
dust nobody won
the intrigue of the platonia dilemma
is less about how to win the game
and more about how to think
about how to win the game it's about
merging math and you
how you behave how other people behave
and how we can use our minds and math
to eclipse our imperfect rationality
so if mr beast launches his version of
the platonia dilemma and it's your turn
to like
the video what do you do what will
everyone else do are you rational are
they rational
is everyone super rational
the most likely scenario for you or
anyone to win
would require all 10 million viewers to
act
super rationally with no cheating
no trolling and each person rolling a
die
with 10 million sides
i think mr beast's million is uh
safe on this one
pocket's not open
[Music]
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you